депутати верховної ради мустафа наймо то
Сергій лещенко про прилюдний шматок
виглядають критий лист граматика
стида влади активісти та політики
викликають шуканий міг волокна т.к. їх
початок реальної боротьби з корупцією не
задувало не темпом реформ в Україні та на
заході 30 секунді битви проти очі
хіба ну ми можемо його проводити реформи
вже спостерігав чутки ти не в Європі знають
нас скільки складно ситуація
а лижі реформи за трибуною самі українці
би врятував троянської українки прикиньтесь і
вона європейську державу
у брюссельському у центрі європейських
політичних дошці дженіс дивова немає їм
всі українські чиновники даси мають
мізерного офіційну зарплату як само
по собі
стоять стимулом для корупції та вирішення чаю
Проте реформа переміщення зарплат
чиновникам не стала себе так наприклад
міністр економіка абромавічус
та фінанси де розшук до лиж не наземки
Іван і вже заміж не забувши печінки людей
вона не чиниш і чиновники травня ніби
висока зарплата та високо вигляд побачилися
як-3 раку та
11 грудня кабмін моя постати перед
парламентом sweet про результат
ідеальності уряду zarik роботи
Серед успіхів уряду яценюка можна назвати
і
пуджа так роботи національної поліції то
видно неба та знатності весь до
реструктуризація за зовнішнього barbu слова
джона робота української дипломатії
середніх dodge уряду арсенію яценюку
адже суть несистемну начебто з
корупцію не правої до нас удава
ensure a формою низ простіше але ведення
бізнесу в Україні
причому у захисник спарти призначають че
президенту і прем'єру назвала ю чена
decker успішності паків даєте він і коти
масштабного розколу у нас раз того
щоб ваша селезінка та тимошенко теж
герой вночі яценюк вдасться позбавитися а
у кріслі а зміни ж буду тебе вище на
рівні міністри в його уряді